the galaxy scruffy-looking nerf-herder
finally got a film all to himself with
solo a Star Wars story and as far as
all-out action filled heist movies go
it's out of this world taking place
about a decade before Han would meet
Luke and his crew in a dingy little
Cantina on Tatooine Solo gives us a
pretty clear backstory about the
troubled optimistic Han despite the
hero's general detachment and
disenchantment from all things Jedi it's
hard to escape common threads dangling
throughout the Star Wars universe from
name-checked bounty hunters to familiar
face masks here are a few details you
may have missed in solo stay golden
you'd be blind to not notice Hans Gould
dice and solo but they have a very
confusing history and even canonical
Star Wars publications can't seem to
agree on what their deal is from their
first on-screen appearance during a new
hope the dice have taken on a life of
their own Star Wars The Force awakens a
visual dictionary includes a picture of
the dice they have standard pips and
they were allegedly used in a game of
soo bahk in which Han won the Falcon
from Lando Calrissian when they make
their reappearance in the last Jedi
their symbols have changed to alien
characters in solo Han hands the diced
Akira before they're separated on
Corellia the dice are returned to him
just before the crew of the Falcon enter
the spice mines of Kessel but they
definitely aren't used during Han soo
bahk showdown with the cheating
Calrissian they're not even used during
Han and Lando's rematch in which Han
actually scores the iconic ship so like
so much of Star Wars lore we're going to
have to dig just a little deeper and
figure out the real story behind those
Karelian chance cubes questions about
Kessel finally we get to see what makes
the Kessel run so dangerous and why it's
such a big deal that Han Solo made it in
less than 12 parsecs setting to rest the
ongoing debate about a parsec being a
unit of distance not time because of the
fancy flying necessary to make it
through the extremely dangerous area of
space finding a viable shortcut and
surviving it is a truly big deal most
viewers remember Kessel because of Hans
boasting the average run takes 20
parsecs but the Falcon made it in 12
that is if you round down by the time a
new hope rolls around
Hans story grows and that number dips to
under 12 during the force awakens Rey
believes the number to be 14 parsecs
which Han quickly corrects but that's
not even the first time Kessel is
mentioned in Star Wars the first mention
occurs in the
first five minutes of a new hope what
are we going to do we'll be sent to the
spice mines of Kessel in Seoul oh we see
that Kessel totally sucks
even though l33 seven staged a pretty
successful robot rebellion in the mines
Star Wars rebels the visual guide
confirms that the mines have regular
rebellions all of which seem to be more
or less unsuccessful even a decade later
Kessel still sucks big bounty of all the
lives lost in solo the definitive end to
a fan-favorite bounty hunter was perhaps
the most surprising and it didn't even
happen on screen are a saying who made a
brief appearance in the Phantom Menace
went on to appear in both canonical Star
Wars comics and multiple episodes of the
Clone Wars where she hung out with Boba
Fett and CAD Bane and even faced down
Jedi warriors ahsoka tano and Pleau kun
and then some time later she was pushed
by Tobias Beckett and met her
unceremonious end that's it for a once
respected bounty hunter what a way to go
also mentioned in passing is bosque the
lizard-like bounty hunter who first
appears in the Empire Strikes Back
diving even deeper into Star Wars lore
the zan sisters are also mentioned at
the same time as bosque while not an
obvious riff on Star Wars legends
continuity zan and zu Pike were a pair
of mercenary sisters who first appeared
in shadows of the Empire if there's any
doubt about their connection consider
teras kasi the martial art mentioned by
kira which is employed by her boss and
Darth Maul among others it's first
mentioned in shadows is used by the pike
sisters shows up in the title of a
terrible video game and is never
mentioned in Canon again until now
legends
even though Disney threw out pretty much
every Star Wars comic and book that was
written before they acquired Lucasfilm
much of the new Canon continuity of Star
Wars is more or less a remix of the old
stuff at one point in Haun's original
wiped out history he joined the Empire
didn't fit in and eventually saved
Chewbacca from the Empire's abuse sound
familiar
that's yes the MA also exists in old
Star Wars lore but it's a cluster of
black holes inside the Kessel run the
idea is essentially the same in solo
plus a horrifying space jellyfish for
good measure the parallels to things
viewers can find in the discarded
history of Star Wars are numerous but
you'll still never ever see Mara Jade on
the big screen sorry guys
crimson dawn Dryden Voss the leader of
the crime syndicate crimson dawn is
something of a collector keen viewers
probably noticed a suit of Mandalorian
armor hanging around in the background
of his office which is of course similar
to the suits worn by the feds
but it's another curiosity in his office
that probably turned even more heads
director Ron Howard announced before the
release of solo that he'd planted an
Indiana Jones Easter Egg in the film
carrying on a long tradition of the two
franchises trading references treasures
from the Sankara stones to the fertility
Idol are hidden throughout the room but
the most obvious treasure is the
gigantic crystal skull that Voss has
prominently displayed fossa skull is
definitely more humanoid than the alien
cranium found in Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull but it's almost definitely a
reference to the Indiana Jones film
aboard the Falcon for decades all we've
really known of the Millennium Falcon is
that it's a temperamental Hardy little
freighter with a weird shape but you
might not have even recognized the ship
and solo during Han and Lando's first
trip we see that the ship is very clean
and also unusually teardrop shaped with
a whole lot of additions made by Lando
himself to make it more of a pleasure
vehicle than one for just serious
business these additions include a cape
room a hollow chest table and some nice
sleeping quarters interestingly the
shape of the old Falcon actually
reflects the original designs of artist
Ralph McQuarrie despite all the damage
by the end of solo one thing we know for
sure remains aboard the Falcon is
Lando's bounty hunter helmet which we
first see in Return of the Jedi
when Lando enters Jabba's palace using
the name Tam tell screech Becket uses
the same helmet to disguise himself on
Kessel digging deep Lando clearly isn't
a fan of mining colonies but by the time
the Empire Strikes Back rolls around
Calrissian is managing Cloud City a
tibanna gas mining colony over Bespin
keep your eyes peeled on the Falcon and
you'll spot a silver model of the colony
among Lando's possessions speaking of
clouds it
also come as a surprise that envis nest
and her cloud riders actually aren't a
completely original creation for solo
they're actually inspired by a band of
marauders who appeared in 1978 Star Wars
number nine but only in appearance the
comic Cloud writers are led by a guy
with a terrible name arrogant ass who
definitely isn't into piracy to help the
rebellion by then Marvel Star Wars
comics were already far off the rails
Jabba the Hutt was a skinny yellow
walrus on two legs while Han was hanging
out with a hedgehog man named hedgy and
a barely clothed crime boss lady named
amazin no thanks weasel and company Solo
doesn't have as many secret cameos as
other recent Star Wars films but a few
are worth mentioning it would be hard to
miss the unusual presence of Clint
Howard brother of director Ron Howard
and a regular face for fans of science
fiction you'll spot him as a robot
Wrangler when we first meet L 337 and
while you won't find c-3po Solo still
features the droids actor Anthony
Daniels as a human named Tok who teams
up with the Wookiees and Chewbacca
during the escape from Kessel and of
course we have Warwick Davis who's been
a part of Star Wars since the very
beginning most notably appearing as
wicket the Ewok of all his Star Wars
characters only one is unmasked weasel a
scuzzy spectator at the Boonta Eve
Padres during the Phantom Menace Davis
appears again in solo as a member of the
cloud riders and once again he's playing
weasel going from a racing junkie on a
dirt planet to be one of the galaxy's
founding freedom fighters is an arc to
parallel anyone else in Star Wars and
it's an arc we'd love to see thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all the school stuff we know
you love to
[Music]